قبل أسبوعين من الهجوم قبل أيام فقط من
سقوط كابول في أيدي طالبان ، كنا
على اتصال مع أحد كبار قادة داعش
الذي قال إن المجموعة كانت مستلقية
وتنتظر اللحظة لتضرب
الكلمات التي تبين أنها نبوية بشكل مخيف ،
لذلك قال هذا القائد  أنه سيجري
مقابلة معنا في فندق هنا في
كابول ويقول إنه لا توجد مشكلة بالنسبة
له في عبور نقاط التفتيش
والوصول إلى العاصمة
لإثبات وجهة نظره ، فقد سمح بفيلمه عند
وصوله إلى المدينة.
طلب أن يتم الاتصال به هو
قائد في تنظيم داعش من كونار قلب
عمليات الجماعة الإرهابية
، وافق على التحدث
بشرط إخفاء هويته
في أحد فنادق كابول ، أخبرنا أن لديه ما يصل
إلى 600 رجل تحت قيادته
بينهم هنود  الباكستانيون
وآسيا الوسطى
مثل العديد من جنوده المشاة الذين
اعتادهم على القتال مع طالبان لكنه يقول
إنهم وقعوا تحت تأثير قوى
أجنبية كنا نعمل في صفوف طالبان
لكن هؤلاء الأشخاص لم يكونوا  توافقنا
معنا من حيث الإيمان ، لذلك ذهبنا إلى
داعش ،
هل تعتقد أنهم ليسوا صارمين بما يكفي
في تطبيقهم للشريعة
كما ترى أنهم لا يستطيعون تقديم مثال واحد
حيث قاموا بفرض عقوبات ثابتة في
القانون الإسلامي حيث قاموا بقطع
عقوبة اللص  رجمت يدها حتى الموت
والزاني رجم حتى الموت
قاتلًا لا يمكنهم تطبيق عقوبات ثابتة في
القانون الإسلامي
لأنهم تحت سيطرة الآخرين
وتنفيذهم لخططهم لذلك لا
نريد تنفيذ خطط شخص آخر
ونريد فقط تطبيق الشريعة إذا  أي شخص
يتفق معنا في هذا هو
أخونا وإلا فإننا نعلن الحرب
معه سواء كان طالبًا أو أي شخص آخر ،
فهل قمت بتنفيذ عمليات إعدام عامة
بتفجيرات انتحارية أشياء من
هذا القبيل
نعم لدي الكثير من الذكريات حيث
كنت أقدم نفسي في هذه  إحدى المشاهد
ذكرى أن طالبان الباكستانية قد
أتوا إلى منطقة ناسيا
وأثناء القتال أسرنا خمسة أشخاص شعر
مقاتلونا بالحماس المفرط.
ضربتهم بالفؤوس ،
كانت الوحشية المروعة هي التي جعلت تنظيم
داعش كا هدفًا أساسيًا لقواتنا
في السنوات الأخيرة ، استهدفت الضربات الجوية
وعمليات القوات الخاصة المجموعة بلا رحمة
في كونار وننغر
وقد انخرطت مجموعتك
في أي قتال معنا قوات خاصة
نعم لقد واجهناها.  في العديد من المناسبات
كان لدينا قتال عن كثب معهم أيضًا ، لقد
اعتادوا الهبوط في الكونار القديم ، لقد
نفذوا غارات جوية لقد
واجهناهم كثيرًا في معارك بالأسلحة النارية
، هل أنت مهتم في النهاية
بتنفيذ هجمات دولية ،
فهذه النقطة أعلى من مستواي.
تزويدك بمعلومات عن
القوات الأفغانية الموجودة معنا خارج البلاد ومن
المحتمل أن تكون طالبان تحت السيطرة ،
هل تعتقد أن ذلك سيسهل
عليك التوسع ،
نعم هذا موجود في خطتنا بدلاً من
العمل حاليًا ، لجأنا إلى
التجنيد فقط للاستفادة من
الفرصة  والقيام بالتجنيد
ولكن عندما
يغادر الأجانب وشعوب العالم أفغانستان يمكننا
إعادة تشغيل o
لقد جاءت عملياتك في تلك اللحظة الآن حيث
رأى العالم بوضوح شديد يوم الخميس هجومًا وحشيًا
على دولة مدمرة
بالفعل وتهديدًا لن يتلاشى
بينما تكمل القوات الأمريكية انسحابها ،
ولم يعلق عبدالنيير على ما إذا
كانت المجموعة مهتمة بالمتابعة.
هجمات عابرة للحدود لكنه قال
إنه يأمل بانسحاب
القوات الأمريكية أنه من المحتمل أن
يتمكنوا من محاولة إقامة خلافة
مثل تلك التي أسسها أبو بكر
البغدادي في سوريا والعراق الآن
يقول معظم محللي الإرهاب أن تنظيم الدولة موجود في العراق.
بعد خمس سنوات على الأقل
من القدرة على شن هجمات دولية ،
لكن هذا الهجوم الدموي على
المطار يثير بالتأكيد أسئلة حقيقية للغاية
حول قدرة طالبان على
السيطرة على مجموعات مثل داعش وما إذا كانت
أفغانستان يمكن أن تصبح مرة أخرى
ملاذًا آمنًا للإرهابيين جناح
كلاريسا cnn doha